we are joined now by samantha power
she's administrator of the us agency for
international development she also
served as u.s ambassador to the united
nations under president barack obama
good morning to you madam ambassador
it's really good to see you again
i want to start with i want to start
with you were at the border two weeks
ago uh in poland and ukraine you were
there i want to know what stood out to
you at that time and what are your
thoughts now because as norah just
reported the stream of people especially
women and children is staggering
thanks gail yeah
one thing to to bear in mind is we all
think back to remember 2015 2016 the
flow of syrians and afghans and others
into europe
that was 2.5 million people over two
years
we are now seeing 2.8 million people
over two weeks effectively to a little
more than two weeks and what stood out
for me is the same thing i'm sure
that is standing out for nora which is
women and children just
disproportionately you see almost no men
and then again the pace of flow the
other thing that stands out which we
don't always see in response to refugee
crises is the open hearts and open doors
of uh you know even on twitter i saw
something this morning where a
journalist was saying does anybody have
room for a family
uh a four a woman and three kids and 50
responses with addresses and so forth
you're just seeing that all around the
world and all around europe
the number of women and children uh
madame ambassador does that pose a
different kind of response or a
different kind of crisis to people who
are handling this and nora also gilivis
reports about possible human trafficking
that's also another layer
well that's one thing that the united
states uh is supporting is efforts to
counter that so-called protection
efforts making sure that they're people
keeping vigilant watch uh at the border
when people who are at their absolute
most vulnerable the wave of refugees
that are coming across now are often
from eastern ukraine some of them have
suffered war wounds almost all of them
are suffering trauma that's different
than when i was there where they were
coming mainly from western ukraine so
that vulnerability uh proposes it poses
a protection risk to be sure and we just
need to make sure that we
the international community has staffed
up sufficiently so that uh people know
uh what to avoid and and that there are
you know law enforcement and others
around
trying to uh you know hone in on any any
predators or people who'd be taking
advantage of this horrible situation
madam ambassador you're right to point
out the tremendous humanitarian spirit
the effort to help people coming over
the border there in poland in particular
at the same time some of the refugees i
spoke with last week were worried that
at some point the welcome will be worn
out and i was wondering if you could
talk a bit about on that subject kind of
the medium to long-term challenge of
handling the need of now nearly three
million people uh coming into new
countries
uh it's an overwhelming challenge
many of the people again especially in
these later waves don't speak any
language other than ukraine
for the kids they're getting absorbed
into european schools it's very
beautiful actually to watch
for example italian kids yesterday
welcoming
ukrainian kids and and so that
adjustment now that europe has decided
to make school benefits work benefits
healthcare benefits
uh available to people coming across
that part should be taken care of by
europe
but the longer term challenge is again
these are women and children the men are
left behind their hearts are breaking
they're living in constant fear of the
phone ringing and getting the worst
possible news and you don't really start
your family life when your family is
separated in that way the other
challenge tony is just your numbers uh i
mean this goes well beyond even the
worst case projections that the un and
others had planned against so the
question of at what point do communities
start to fill up do homes
start no longer to be able to offer that
welcome map because they're already
hosting a family i mean we are not that
far from that point
madam ambassador do you feel that the
united states has a responsibility to
also accept some of those refugees
well as you know we've already announced
of course that any ukrainians who are
here who were scheduled to leave or
their visas were expiring are welcome to
stay the ukrainians i met with were very
focused on staying close because they
all believe they're going to win and
that they're going to be going home soon
so so far again we haven't heard an
overwhelming uh desire on the part of
ukrainians to go further afield but
we're going to look at everything to do
our part of course to respond to this
truly
once in a generation humanitarian
emergency
madam ambassador you wrote a very famous
book called the problem from hell about
genocide genocide is a term that
ukrainians are using to describe what
russia is doing to them there are
reports of cities encircled civilians
being starved out
when you think about the need for
american intervention could you walk us
through how we should all be viewing
this is there a point at which the
crisis becomes so severe the suffering's
so severe that something more has to be
done
well i think what you're seeing is the
use of the tools in the toolbox to
change putin's calculus and to get him
to de-escalate from this horror that
he's inflicting on on the ukrainian
people putin doesn't seem to know how to
fight another way other than this way
this is the grozny approach this is the
aleppo approach that he took siding with
bashar al-assad
and it's horrific and what we can do as
an international community led by the
united states and europe but but now
joined by countries in latin america and
east asia and beyond is rally the world
to impose sufficiently severe costs
that russia experiences a strategic
defeat but also
that in these peace talks that the
ukrainians keep showing up for wanting
again and again to pursue
a diplomatic path a diplomatic
resolution that russia shows up for
those these talks because of those costs
uh looking to de-escalate and that
hasn't happened yet obviously but the
combination of increased security
assistance humanitarian assistance that
is flowing more and more now into
ukraine the welcome that we offer
ukrainians who make it out of the
country that puts us in a position again
uh it's not happening soon enough for
anybody
but ultimately for this war to end
all right ambassador power we thank you
for your time this morning
thanks gail